gyeo storm is directed by Dean Devlin
and stars Gerard Butler as one of the
smartest scientists who ever lived who
designed a giant Space Station orbiting
Earth called dutchboy its job is to
control possible weather disasters that
could plague mankind and when something
goes wrong what's called a geo storm
threatens to destroy the entire
population Dean Devlin was a producer of
Stargate independence day the 1998
Godzilla he has collaborated with roland
emmerich the king of disaster movie
directors for a very long time and this
is his directorial debut and what does
he direct a 1990s disaster storm porn
movie because that's what this is some
of those movies can be very entertaining
if you view them from the right lens
that usually being a party with friends
when you really don't care and you're
laughing at everything that happens
because that's exactly what this movie
is made for however this one
unfortunately just like every single one
of them tries to take itself very
seriously and it follows the exact same
formula of virtually every disaster
movie made by Roland Emmerich or Dean
Devlin as a producer in the past there
is not one single surprise in this
entire film every single moment can be
predicted most of the dialogue is very
obvious jokes laced with pop-culture
references political discussions with a
lot of jargon thrown at you and the
central bromance between Jim Sturgess
and Gerard Butler who play actual
brothers is one of the more emotional
parts of the film they always cut back
to this and they try to make it be that
emotional weight that keeps you
connected with these characters the
problem is the casting here is
absolutely atrocious I don't buy for a
second that Butler is the world's
smartest scientist I don't buy for a
second that Jim Sturgess works with the
president there are only a handful of
principal characters in this film that I
actually bought into Abbie Cornish as a
Secret Service agent and Ed Harris as Ed
Harris because he's ed Harris and he
lends credibility to just about anything
you don't really have to write
great dialogue to make Idi Harris
credible this is that type of movie
where every major character
confrontation is resolved by somebody
getting punched in the face and it's
always that asshole character that we're
told we're supposed to hate because he's
being really mean to the good guys it's
that type of film where the third act
tension is derived from a screen saying
Gio storm alert and then a countdown
letting us all know when the Geo storm
will occur I mean it doesn't get better
than this guys this is storm porn at its
best and it's filled with so many
implausible moments like astronauts
zooming through space flipping back and
forth like ten times faster than sound
or Bullock did in gravity somehow
attaching themselves to something well a
thousand pieces of debris are flying
everywhere like meteorites it's the type
of movie where when someone reviews
security camera footage the security
camera appears to be on a dolly slowly
moving towards its subject and just like
1998's Godzilla our principal characters
are fleeing from some force of nature in
a taxicab and of course they're
outrunning it this film became so
tedious and boring to watch that I found
myself more interested in the changing
length and Colour of Butler's facial
hair because apparently this movie went
under a lot of reshoots even seems to be
changing body mass sighs like he seems
more muscular in certain takes and then
less muscular and others his facial hair
goes from really dark black to a little
grayish black and then longer and
shorter guys this movie is a mess it's
bookended by Butler's daughter narrating
the film talking about how great her dad
is it's it's it's exactly what you
thought it would be a hundred percent
exactly what you thought it would be and
if you want to go to a theater and watch
an incredibly stupid disaster movie with
a bunch of special effects that really
doesn't have as much of the disaster
stuff as you might expect it's actually
more about scientists trying to prevent
that from happening but it's just
another movie that somehow is filled
with a bunch of stars about some
disaster that's going to happen and Dean
Devlin of course
is involved with it I'm gonna give Geo
store Maddy if you watch this movie
honestly not caring you can overlook a
lot of the flaws this movie certainly
didn't make me mad I knew exactly what I
was getting into when I walked into the
theater I was ready to be surprised by
anything but it follows beat four beaten
and sometimes almost shot-for-shot the
types of disaster movies that Dean
Devlin has always been involved in so I
don't really know what to say oh my god
now if you guys follow me on Facebook or
Twitter you know that we recently
completed a short film it's about 35
minutes long it's called auditorium 6
and it's going to be premiering next
week here in Cleveland Ohio
we're also submitting it to a lot of
film festivals and eventually down the
road after it's done a hopeful Film
Festival run of some kind I will put it
on some form of VOD service so people
around the world who aren't in the
United States can hopefully watch and
enjoy our short film we made a lot of
people have asked about this I don't
know exactly what we're going to do with
that in the future I would love to make
a blu-ray I would love to put it on
Amazon video direct I will see if I can
but for now if you guys want to come see
our film there's a link in the
description below for tickets the
premiere is next week October 25th it's
6 bucks for a ticket you can see the
movie there's a Q&A afterwards with
myself in the cast and I have 250
posters that I printed off that myself
and the cast will sign and giveaway and
I hope to see as many of you there as
can make it if you're in Ohio or the
surrounding area I'd love to meet you
and show you our film because we're all
very proud of it and we're excited to
share it with you so I hope to see you
there that link is in the description
below as I said guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nice
[Music]